hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and today we're talking about a
somewhat difficult subject which is
cancer and how we can try to treat and
prevent cancer from taking lives it's a
difficult subject of course because I
and I'm sure many other people in the
audience are familiar with people who
have passed away because of cancer the
two leading causes of any kind of death
in the United States are heart disease
and cancer by a wide margin these two
things and I think at least you know
informally I don't have any data and I
want to valorize one way of dying over
another but my informal impression is
that cancer is much crueler than heart
disease in many ways can come on people
who are otherwise perfectly healthy it
can appear in people relatively young I
know people in their 40s and 50s who
have been diagnosed and the way that we
have of treating it is not very good it
involves a very painful process a very
drawn-out long process that often fails
that often even though we do everything
we can cancer still claims a victim so
today's guest on mindscape is Ozma raza
who is the Chand soon she young
professor of medicine at Columbia
University she's an oncologist she's
been doing cancer research for a long
time she has a new book out called the
first cell the human costs of pursuing
cancer to the last and as I said we all
know people who have died of cancer
Ezra's husband who was also an
oncologist was diagnosed with cancer and
it eventually claimed his life so no
matter how much you know no matter how
expert you are in the field this can
come to get you and there's really
nothing you can do about it so ah SRA's
angle is that we should shift a lot of
our resources from fighting cancer once
it's already spread through the body to
finding cancer as soon as it appears
that's the name of the book the first
cell the first cell in the body that
goes cancerous of course many people
would agree many doctors many
oncologists would agree that that would
be great if we could do it but the
argument is that we can do it there are
things that we know that would improve
the rates at which we find cancer very
very early but we're just not put
the resources to doing that that we
could and one of the wonderful things
about Alger Hiss book and it'll come out
in the conversation is that she's a very
warm human kind of doctor and there's a
lot of stories in the book about
individual people and their struggles
with cancer and we talked a little bit
about the fact that I would be you know
I would have a tough time being an
oncologist talking with people who had
cancer all the time but author really
appreciates it thinks it's a privilege
that she gets to you know help people in
this crucial moment in their lives going
one way or another so it's a very kind
of uplifting conversation despite the
gloomy topic overall so this is the last
mindscape podcast the last regular one
anyway of 2019 I take a two-week break
for the holidays there may or may not be
another holiday message like I did last
time but one way or the other I wanted
to thank everyone who's been listening
patreon supporters especially but really
anyone who is listening to mindscape
once or every single week my thanks goes
out to you it's sort of amazing to me
that I can sit here and talk and I can
send an email to some brilliant
accomplished person somewhere in the
world and say can I talk to you for an
hour or two and they will say yes
because I have this podcast I hope
you're enjoying it as much as I am and I
know that I have some really good guests
lined up for the schedule next year
already
so 2020 is going to be another great
year for mindscape enjoy your holidays
and let's go
[Music]
okay elsewhere Raza thanks for coming on
the mindscape podcast delighted to be
here Sean
this is uh just so everyone out there in
podcast land knows we've never met
before but we have you know knowledge of
each other over the internet for many
years now you're part of the collective
that makes three quarks daily the famous
blog site is that right yes my younger
brother Abbas resides the chief editor
in chief of it and what kind of things
do you contribute there for the last 15
years I've been posting two stories
daily very occasionally one and one of
them is a story related to some kind of
scientific news that's just been
released or a scientific article but the
other is general interest because I have
many other interests so it could be
literature philosophy music art anything
well that's what's great about the
website it really does bring things
together in a way that is remanent
reminiscent of the mind speed podcast
here so that makes you a perfect guest
and also what makes you perfect guesses
you have a book that just came out is
that right or coming out called the
first cell and it's not about the origin
of life it's about cancer and you're an
oncologist and I thought I want to get
into what cancer is how we treat it and
so forth but I can't help but ask about
the very moving personal story that you
opened the book with could you tell the
audience about that well the book is
titled the first cell but equally
important is the subtitle of the book
which is and the human costs of pursuing
cancer to the last so this is a book not
about cancer it is about cancer patients
yes and the purpose of this book shown
is to bring back the patient front and
center into every discussion we have
about cancer no matter how deeply and
rigorously scientific it is we have to
ask the question at every point
where does the patient benefit from this
or is hurt by it and so as a result of
having this goal in mind I have told
many patient stories as well as patients
who are in the treatment with me right
now their stories they have told in
their own words hmm
but after I started to write it I
realized that it would be insincere of
me if I did not include my own right
because if I'm going into such
granularity about people suffering and
pain
it's not fair to shield myself if you're
asking other people to open up in this
way then yes that's exactly right and so
it has been 18 years now since my
husband Harvey Price lured I'd I have
never spoken about it to anyone or
written about it but what made me come
out and write it and then write in as
much detail as possible because that's
what I was demanding of my other
patients and their families now this
personal story became like a red line
running throughout the book through
every chapter and then there's a whole
chapter devoted to Harvey you asked me
to tell you something about this
personal story I opened the book with so
this is the background of why I put it
there and then of course Harvey was my
mentor since I am 24 years of age we
later got married he was the head of the
Cancer Center and in an ironic and cruel
twist of fate he got the very disease he
had dedicated his life to cure since he
was 15 years old cancer leukemia and he
suffered inexplicable indignities at the
hands of this disease over a course of
almost five years our daughter was three
years old when he girl was diagnosed and
eight years old when he died and so in
this sort of
dizzying disorienting period what I
experienced needed some distance of time
as well even in even to verbalize some
of those things so in a way the book is
a combination of my personal story but
that of the people I take care of and
that of the disease I study so it's
several books in one I guess yeah yeah
you know I also had a very good friend
Michael who was an oncologist and was
diagnosed with cancer and eventually
died of it and they had nothing else it
reminds us that we really don't know so
much about the disease that people who
know the most are still helpless in the
face of it and there's something about
cancer that is especially cruel how it
happens apparently randomly you can be
relatively young it takes years and the
you can reach a point where there's not
much you can do and the greatest cruelty
is that it is a silent killer that it
can grow to an advanced stage within
your body and you have no inkling about
it in fact there's a very very
interesting study that was done some
years ago Sean where people who have
been long-term smokers try to quit many
many times and when they finally managed
to quit and not go back because they
quit go back quit go back finally when
they managed to quit and inordinate
lehigh number of them end up with lung
cancer really so a study was done to
show why and it turns the conclusion was
that most likely they could stop only
because something internal finally it
wasn't there was a selection right right
so there is something but we tend to
ignore it completely and
because it's such at such a subconscious
level so when you say that something
very terrible about cancer very unique
about it is that it is a silent killer
and just so hopefully many people in the
audience have not seen cancer up close
or had to deal with it let's so let's
back up explain what cancer is it's not
a simple even thing to explain what it
is right there's many varieties and many
manifestations to begin with the very
simple thing is that every living cell
which is normal has a limited number of
proliferations or divisions it can
undergo this is known as the hayflick
limit that after 40 to 45 cell divisions
it will either undergo a process of
committing suicide or be killed by other
things or it will dial down all its
activities and enter a state of
senescence and be useful no longer I
mean by the way that's worth a podcast
all by itself that fact right because
you know amoebas don't have that
property they can just keep dividing
forever so we complicated multicellular
organisms have built in a lifetime you
know a suicide mechanism for our own
cells that just fascinates me to no end
okay yeah it looks like a too distracted
and cancer cells overcome the safely
climate and become immortalized that
they don't die so to me the definition
of a cancer is just that that a cell
which is now capable of infinite number
of divisions and what causes cancer
really there are some very specific
events that can give rise to it but most
of the time it's a random event and
probably I would say at least 60% of all
cancers happen because of DNA copying
errors as the cell is dividing and is it
is it correct to say that one thing we
do know about cancer is that it involves
a change in the DNA it's some sort of
genetic mutation one way or the other
only partly correct okay because genetic
change is one thing but in inside the
cell itself
but also control of those a cellular
function could come from an external
source however ultimately it is the cell
gone gone rogue by itself running amok
so in the end you are right that there
has to be a genetic component to every
cancer cell and is it just is it merely
that it grows without bound or does the
size and functionality of the shape of
the cell also change probably as a
result of the cancerous changes
everything goes haywire really itself no
useful function anymore and it does
change size shape form when you have I
guess since I know so little about this
my ignorance is going to show when you
have a tumor for a sort of cancer that
is stationary in your body does that
grow because the cells simply keep
dividing or because the individual cells
puff up or is it a mixture of both it's
because cells are dividing and making a
big mass around them I think think of
cancer is something which tends to
evolve like life itself the same
constraints and the same principles that
apply to evolution apply to initiation
expansion growth of a cancer also so one
cancer cell let's say divides and
becomes two each time a cell divides it
has to copy its entire DNA which is
about three billion base pairs so on the
whole at each division a cell will
retain three to four new mutations now
most of these mutations are passive
which means they're not they're harmless
but some of these if one of these happen
to occur in a vital gene for example
which is controlling proliferation or
which is responsible for growth control
which are known as tumor suppressor
genes if these mutations
happen in one of those vital genes then
the function of the cell is affected but
then let's say now overcomes growth
control because of this mutation that is
mutation which will be termed as the
driver or the founder mutation so the
first cell will have the founder
mutation but each time it divides into
two Shawn that's the problem it's going
to pick up new passenger mutations that
may not change its proliferative or
doubling ability but it can change its
metabolism its response to drugs its
ability to be more aggressive and it's
dividing so much more rapidly than
normal cells that it starts making a
mass getting more and more blood supply
to self becomes a hot area because it
needs nutrition to to help itself but
the point is that this mass of cells now
after like thirty doublings may have
nothing or very little in common except
the founding mutation with the original
cell so in other words it's a constantly
metamorphosis metamorphosing mutating
transforming dividing selectively
evolving sort of collection of cells so
what I say is that treating cancer as
one disease is like treating Africa as
one country it is and it's a moving
target because let's say I remove a
tumor from my lung today to study its
sensitivity to 50 drugs and find two
drugs which are very effective by the
time I found the two drugs at six weeks
later because of all the tests I did
cancer has moved on the drug was the
drugs would have worked six weeks ago
and this is one of the reasons that we
have not been able to control advanced
cancers until now the outcome for a
patient with advanced disease is no
different than it was in 1930s is there
is it if we put into an evolutionary
context the biological context is there
any reason why cancer happens as there
some purpose served for
biologically I have this vague feeling
that elephants don't get cancer or
something like that there are different
stories about different species having
different susceptibilities is there a
grand theory of all this no short answer
is known that's it's called petros
paradox because the idea would be that
if the number of mutations increase each
time a cell divides then a larger
organism should have a higher chance of
having cancer right just by that alone
more so it's exactly not true because
and it's not the opposite either because
for example mice and humans humans
should have more cancer it's not true
whales almost never get cancer for a
different reason than elephants don't we
think we know why elephants are not
getting cancer because they have 20
copies of a tumor suppressor gene called
p53 and that those genes are redundant
so that if one is mutated another one
takes its place and another one and so
tumor suppressor gene p53 which is known
as the guardian of the genome because
it's constantly surveying the genome for
mutations and forcing the cell which
shows a mutation to commit suicide if
that gene gets mutated and it stops
performing its normal Guardian function
then the cell can become cancerous but
if you have redundant copies of that
gene then the opposite would happen that
is you know this next copy would kick in
even if one is mutated however when this
was replicated in animal models to
produce two overexpress this gene or to
have insert multiple copies of these
genes the results were not so great
because you know what happened the
animals number one didn't get cancer but
aged dramatically okay and died of aging
well I was going to ask cuz I did I've
never heard of the tumor suppressor gene
again I'm not an expert in this area but
it sounds like yeah we should just have
lots of tumor suppressor genes but it's
not that simple it's not that simple and
so it would be simplistic to think that
elephants who are large animals and
should be getting lots of cancers don't
get it is all because they have 20
copies of p53 we'd like to think so but
let me pause for a second to talk about
policy genius.com
I know the probably shopping for
insurance is something that if you
haven't already done it doesn't seem
that exciting it seems like one of those
things you're gonna put low on your list
of priorities especially the holidays
are coming up you have other things on
your mind so policy genius makes it easy
to shop for insurance where there's life
insurance health insurance disability
insurance or what have you you can go to
one website type in what you want and
you can get a list of different options
with all the prices explicitly there and
once you apply the policy G News team
will handle all the paperwork and red
tape you can save up to $1500 or more
per year by using policy genius to
compare life insurance policies alone so
if you need life insurance but aren't
sure where to start why not start a
policy genius.com
it only takes a few minutes to find the
right insurance policy apply cross
another thing off your end-of-the-year
to-do list
policy genius it's nice to get it right
so aside from the grand biological
theories what about human beings cancer
is quite common on the scale of things
that kill us in the world today writing
what well should a typical American
let's say sorry let me back up or the
numbers very different from the u.s. to
Europe to Africa to Asia etc actually no
okay the only difference in numbers that
appears is because some places keep good
statistics others don't so the only
numbers we can rely on unfortunately are
only Western countries and a few
countries in Asia and Africa but in
general wherever it has been looked at a
few things are very clear number one no
age is immune from cancer so from birth
to death a person is can get cancer any
time however it's much more common as
agent one sees so not just because
you're older but because the likelihood
per year goes up
when you're older I actually call it the
midst of aging to remember it easily
it's an acronym missed M stands for
mutations so just remember that by the
time you are older each cell has now
gone through multiple mutations so each
cell has more mutations in it and if you
think about this great sand pile game
that pair back one of my patients that I
described in great detail in the book
came up with was that if you are
dropping grains of sand it forms a
little pile but this sand pile after you
keep dropping the sand will eventually
collapse the last grain of sand which
caused the pile to collapse was no
different than thousands of grains that
came before it it was the pile that had
become unstable so it's not necessarily
something a mutation that causes cancer
it could just be that with age many
things are becoming unstable in the body
so one of them is the number of
mutations have increased per cell a
second one is the immune system may be a
little more decrepit now it's not as
efficient in eliminating the abnormal
misbehaving cells then subunit is I in
missed yes and then the S is stands for
senescence which we mentioned this
briefly earlier that after the hayflick
limit is reached and cells dialed down
their activities and enter acquiescence
period in which they are really not
performing any more useful function they
are incapable of dividing anymore so
they'll never become cancerous but they
have a minimal level of metabolic
function going on to stay alive so now
more and more cells are entering
senescence with age and what is
happening is they are producing a ton of
garbage and a garbage system in the body
is becoming I can feel it the garbage
system is now becoming overwhelmed and
what happens then is that more and more
of this toxic
Tyrael starts collecting and poisons the
soil or the micro environment in which
the seed or the cell is living so the S
really is not just senescence but the
soil is will of the body becomes more
pro-inflammatory which means these
inflammatory protein cytokines are
accumulating and causing normal cells to
have less than robust existence whereas
supporting the proliferation and growth
of something which is even slightly out
of balance but has a selective growth
advantage in that setting so it's
fitness of the landscape to the seed
that's existing in it and the last I'm
sorry just to make that clear the
senescence cells as you say they're not
the ones are gonna become cancerous but
they make all the cells around them more
prone to it by weakening them in some
sense yes by poisoning the atmosphere in
which they are living poisoning the soil
in which they exist that's exactly right
and the last thing T that you see one of
the problems is that I'll give you the
example of the bone marrow in a normal
healthy adult half of the marrow is fat
cells and the other half is
hematopoietic cells which means the
cells which make blood which do all the
things blood is supposed to do by the
time we are let's say 70 years old
this ratio changes so that 70% of it is
now just empty space which is filled
with fat cells and only 30% are active
cells so in in this setting what happens
is that every living cell is under the
control of signals from other cells from
within itself from the soil in which it
exists from blood vessels that are
coming from nerve endings that are
feeding onto it
the increase in distance between
controlling cells and those that are the
targets the effector and the effector
cells just by increasing that their
geographic distance you know that can
also lead to slight change in for
example a suppressive behavior if a cell
is growing too much then it would be
controlled and it would be told not to
and yet it's suddenly taking off so I do
think that with age the incidence of
cancer increases because you asked me
about is it the same all over the world
and is it the same disease all over the
world what we see is in America for
example 1.7 million new cancer cases are
diagnosed in adults in children fourteen
thousand a year so you see the
difference that age makes they're there
but there's a big difference yeah yeah
so there is a big difference in age and
but as I said no age is really immune
from it I mean all these facts about
aging tangentially to this conversation
but I've had previous conversations with
experts on aging and you know there are
people out there who want to stop or
reverse aging and this reminds us how
hard it is how many things are going on
under the umbrella of what we call aging
no I don't think I mean of course it's
going to be very hard like curing cancer
is like you're going to cure aging
basically but one thing we can target is
instead of always running after disease
and treating disease preventing it right
sure absolutely I want to get there or
just to drive at home how important that
is again for the folks in the audience
who haven't had to go through this
personally how do we treat cancer in a
typical patient these days is there a
standard way we've all heard of
radiation therapy and chemotherapy and
so forth yes so the good news is that
68% cancers we are that are diagnosed
today are cured but cured with what the
same
things we were using like 60 70 years
ago / poison burn surgery chemotherapy
radiation therapy the same things of
course there are some very small pockets
of rare cancers for which other things
are used two of them have targeted
therapies one is chronic myeloid
leukemia being treated with the mater
net which is one gene causing a problem
and one magic bullet that targets it
that's the one cancer that has been
really paradigmatic in the sense that it
seemed to establish a model that cancer
is a disease that is caused by a genetic
change which can be targeted by a drug
successfully sadly it turned out that
for all of the cancers there's many many
genetic mutations and no single drug
seems to be working so basically
chemotherapy is an indiscriminate
killing of normal as well as abnormal
cells and that's what we are still using
the 32 percent patients that we are not
curing their outcome today is as bad as
it was 50 years ago and so what should
we do what hey you part of the message
of your book is that of course we don't
have all the answers you don't have all
the answers either but we do choose to
spend our resources trying different
things and you have a specific angle you
think that we should be pushing toward
yes the angle is of course that of the
first cell that instead of forever
chasing and trying to kill the last cell
we have been trying to do that for 50
years we have done it successfully in a
very small number of rare cancers but
for the majority of patients who present
with the common types of cancers
you know gi colorectal lung ovarian
kidney cancer I mean for these types of
cancers we really haven't made a big
striking blow against them in using the
same / poison burn approaches
let me let me I should have asked this
earlier but we speak of cancer being in
remission we typically don't speak of
cancer being cured right can you explain
the difference there I mean it's a
technicality where oncologists insists
that if someone has been cancer-free for
five years at least then we call them
cured okay but otherwise if there is no
evidence of even microscopic disease we
only will call it remission and that's
because we are never sure whether
there's so little of cancer there yes
that it may recur but after five years
if it recurs the chances are there it's
a new cancer okay that's fair and is it
if there are genetic components to
turning a cell into a cancer cell is it
just one mutation would be enough do you
need a combination of mutations because
if the latter then you can imagine that
even if you get rid of all the actually
cancerous cells there's still a bunch of
cells left over that are ready to become
cancerous because they have all the one
of the mutations yes that's the answer
is yes there is always that danger so
you were talking about we have a certain
amount of resources how are we going to
spend them I think before we get into it
I want to give you a few statistics sure
the first is as I said our strategy has
been since time immemorial to get rid of
the cancer somehow so we see a disease
is already drought once it's already
developed yes we see it we want to get
rid of it and if we get rid of what we
can see then we still assume that
microscopic disease may be present so we
try to kill it with supplemental
adjuvant therapies like chemotherapy
radiation therapy so we not only remove
a woman's breast we now give her tons of
both of these as well over time we have
learned to use these things better and
that has changed but I wanted to give
you some statistics
first of all patients who are diagnosed
with early-stage disease 90% can be
cured but those who are advanced with
advanced disease 90% or more 100% are
going to die with the common
kinds of cancers really that makes sense
but it's a dramatic shift yeah so we
know that early detection is more
amenable to treatment it's true for
every disease the earlier you detect the
better you are able to treat it before
you let things go completely out of hand
now I started my career Sean in 1977 by
studying and treating patients with
acute myeloid leukemia today in 2019 I'm
using the exact same combination of two
chemotherapy drugs popularly known as
seven and three to treat acute myeloid
leukemia I was using seven and three
then I'm using it now can you imagine I
see 30 to 40 patients every week for all
these years can you imagine the same
conversation with the same side effects
and the same dreadful results over and
over honestly I cannot imagine being an
oncologist I think that you need a sort
of strength of will and generosity that
would tax me a little bit but I give you
credit for having all those
conversations thank you for saying that
but I have the opposite view you have
such exquisite sensitivity because I
listen to your all your great courses as
well as your podcasts and I think you
have exquisite sensitivity and you will
make an excellent doctor
and we all have to do what we have to do
in life that's right and when a human
being needs us then it is actually an
immense privilege Sean to be there for
someone just root and help them if we
can't help them live a better life we
help them have a better death we help
them at every step of the way and to me
there is the most sublime form of grace
that you can see the most the greatest
acts that you witness in our scene in
the nobility of endurance that is
manifested by these patients and a
corresponding level of frustration that
you're having the same conversation with
them about the same treatments 40 years
later yeah and we should be able to do
better
I'll give you one example my daughter
shares arts best friend Andrew three
years ago at 22 years of age got
diagnosed because he had pain and
tingling in an arm by the time he
reached the emergency room he was
already quadriplegic the neurosurgeons
when they operated on him found a 9
centimeter brain tumor which they could
only partly remove so every oncologist
knew from day zero that this poor boy's
chances of survival are zero point zero
zero do you know the first thing he said
when he woke up Sean from the anesthesia
he said was mom don't worry just call
Azra she's on the cutting edge she's
gonna find a cure for me no no how
ashamed I felt how can I ever look at
myself in the mirror that this poor boy
I stood by his bedside realizing how
badly we have failed Andrew and the
question I ask myself is how many
Andrews will it take and to address that
last point I wanted to bring you
up-to-date about Andrew that three weeks
before he died which was two years ago
now they brought him a form to sign do
not resuscitate we call it a DNR form
and have all z23 now diagnosed at 22
he's 23 how is a 23 year old supposed to
sign his own death certificate he sent
it away he said I'm not signing it so
they took it away that night his father
came over to spend the night with him as
soon as his father came he called the
people back to bring this form signed it
saying I could not sign it in front of
my mother and sister this is the grace
I'm talking about that his 23 year old
young man who's dying is protecting his
mother
well we we're all going to die someday
we all know it intellect
but you can certain point you reach as a
cancer patient do you know it in a
slightly different way in a more
visceral way that it's coming and how
you react how you behave says something
about who you are definitely it is my
opinion that the kind of lonely courage
that this boy and that all the patients
that I'm taking care of really show at
one point or another in the course of
their illness that's the kind of courage
that needs Nations to dedicate monuments
to now you know some of it is it's the
kind of courage that Harper Lee has
defined beautifully she says Shawn
courageous knowing that you are licked
before you start but you start anyway
and you see it through to the end and
that is what and rooted from the start
he knew his licked but he went through
round upon round of chemo radiation more
surgery immune therapy more chemo more
radiation more immune therapy more
surgery he went through everything and
saw it to the very end and that's the
kind of courage that really is what I am
talking about after my husband died we
found in his wallet a beautiful saying
beautiful line that he had written
something to the effect that I know
there is no good end for what I am going
through but I have to do it because I'm
a man and a man is responsible for
himself and it's difficult because we
don't either sort of narrowly as a
medical establishment or broadly as a
society deal very well with how to die
right how to help people dying how to
admit that death is coming how to face
it you know there's individual moments
of courage and grace but there is not
we tend to avoid it right we tend to
live in denial do you think you think we
can change that do you think that how
bad is it or is there is it better than
I think it is first I want to quote
Emily Dickinson beautiful beautiful
writer I measure every grief I meet with
analytic eyes I wonder if it weighs like
mine or has a different size I wonder if
they bore it long or did it just begin I
cannot find the date of mine it's been
so long a pain I wonder if it hurts to
live and if they have to try and weather
could they choose between they would not
rather die you see death is not an
option that is not a choice as you say
death is coming so for all of us but for
those individuals who start hearing the
footsteps of death approaching what goes
through their minds is impossible for us
to imagine unless we are in those shoes
so I think it is impossible for us to
switch places easily however one of the
main reasons to write the book for me
was exactly what you said that I'm
getting tired of everyone only promoting
the positive anecdote as if dying is a
failure dying is not a failure denying
death is a failure and the main
difference between humans and Greek gods
is that we accept mortality in the final
analysis look at Andrew at 23 he
accepted mortality and is trying to
protect the living because he knows he
is dying but he's trying to shield his
mother and his sister that is the
sublime grace of humanity
and that is what makes my life a
privilege to live instead of people's
feeling sorry that I have to take care
of dying patients they should be envious
that I get to see humanity in its
noblest of forms basically it boils down
to are we prolonging life or prolonging
death by the current techniques that's
the question I'm asking in the book that
if the 68% patients we are curing today
with cancer why are we curing them with
Paleolithic treatments that belong in
the Stone Age why are we still using
chemotherapy for God's sake it's like
taking a baseball bat to a dog to get
rid of its fleas it's so horrifying the
toxic effects and the 32 percent
patients who present with advanced
disease who we know we are not
benefiting we are being bringing drugs
to their bedside which have a failure
rate of 95% and the 5% that are FDA
approved and are ostensibly great
successes they should have failed
because they are only prolonging
survival by a few months for a small
mature minority so if hundred patients
are given this drug X twenty to thirty
percent will respond for a few months 70
to 80 percent will never respond and
suffer all the toxic side effects
hundred percent will suffer physical
toxicity of the drug and financial
toxicity do you know Sean that today in
America 42 percent individuals who are
diagnosed with cancer 42 percent become
financially ruined by two plus years I
was gonna inspect that I didn't know
that and that's astonishing number it is
untenable it is unsupportable it is
unconscionable it would be one thing if
and then they lived happily ever after
yes they're not even living
so why are we bringing drugs to the
market or to the bedside which are
benefiting a small fraction of patients
for a few days and hurting everybody and
ruining 42% not just themselves their
next generation to come so the question
is what should we do then we have
present patients to worry about and then
what are our plans for the future either
we can keep doing the same thing and
there is some benefit to hanging on to
your ideas forever but sometimes giving
up bad ideas can also help okay we have
milked the most out of chemo and
radiation even for the 68% we are curing
there should be better solutions in my
opinion we don't have to torture people
and for this 32% we shouldn't be saying
either you die of cancer or you die of
the drugs we give you and also be
financially ruined so but we have an
limited number of resources how are we
going to spend it actually let me let me
interrupt you just there because I want
to I don't let this terrible fact about
financial ruin and the grim mortality
rates go by without wondering about the
causality just a little bit let me just
put this on the table or are some people
or groups benefiting financially from
the current regime do they have a vested
interest in keeping it like this my
answer is not some people but everyone
is benefiting except a cancer patient
why do I say this I think it's very easy
for the public to imagine the worst
possible things about the evil
pharmaceutical companies but I ask you
this question if you go to the corner
drugstore and buy a hundred packet of
100 band-aids you cost you 399 or
something if you go to a hospital and
they put a bandaid on you one band-aid
will cost 75 dollars so where's the drug
company in this equation and what about
all the extra imaging or extra scanning
people are getting and what about all
the therapies that oncologists are
giving to patients who they know will
not be benefited 80% chances they
not people why aren't we holding them
responsible the question is I'm one of
them every criticism applies to me as
much as it does to any other oncologist
why am i doing it when I know 7 and 3 is
so bad why am i giving it because
otherwise I'll go to jail because a
group of key opinion leaders in the
field have reviewed all the data and
come up with guidelines and it's a good
thing to try to make something more
uniform try to bring some method to the
madness so that lets say for pancreatic
cancer patient is diagnosed with stage 4
disease these three drugs will be used
in first-line treatment then these three
and second line these two in third line
treatment that is the guideline if I
divvy eight from doing that then I'm
opening myself to legal challenges so
I'm also giving those drugs knowing full
well that it will only hurt 80% of the
people practically 100% in the end for a
benefit of a few months the other thing
is we tell everything to the patient
it's not like we are doing it without
sign consent forms and they are the ones
choosing it also because life is so
precious and dying is so scary that most
of my patients will tell me even if
there is one a million one in a million
chance what do I have to lose let me
sign up for it and do it so it's a very
strange kind of system where everyone is
to be blamed but no one can actually
assume the blame so where does
individual responsibility end in
society's responsibility begin these are
the fundamental questions I'm raising in
the book and it's it is fundamentally
difficult if you're told there's a 1%
chance of survival a 99% chance that you
will die and your family will be
financially ruined saying no I'm not
even going to try to take that 1% is
difficult or more in terms of policy
saying well we should spend less because
most of what we're spending is being
wasted people are going to worry that if
you're spending less you're not doing as
good a job
it was honestly hard to balance these so
here's the thing I'm saying that if 95%
of the drugs we bring to the bedside are
failing the first question is why are
they failing because whatever we did to
bring them to the bedside is a failing
model what is that failing platform
where we are even developing these drugs
to bring to the bedside mostly in
animals or in in vitro petri dishes or
in extremely artificial conditions that
we keep insisting will be extrapolated
to humans well over and over it's been
shown that doesn't happen so there's a
time to simply take off the blinders and
admit the truth cancer is too
complicated for us to understand every
intracellular signaling pathway and then
try to fix it because it keeps it has
moved on also I know you have strong
opinions about studies being done on
mice very strong opinions and and mice
are the model organism in which we test
our ideas about cancer right so I don't
want to be miss quoted here I'll make
myself very clear because very often
I am misquoted and then I get hate mail
for months years not mine no it was not
the main point I want to make is this
animal models are excellent by logic
tools where we can test a large number
of very intricate questions about all
sorts of biologic phenomena there is no
question about it or most of the
advances have occurred even in cancer
because of studying animals the only
thing I object to which I try to be as
specific as possible and I'm glad you're
giving me this chance to explain my
point of view accurately the only thing
I object to is you can't create a tumor
in an animal treat it with some drug and
think now when you use the same drug in
the human tumor it's going to have the
same results so for drug development
models have not been helpful but this
was used all the time but they are used
in these preclinical testing platforms
in fact you can't bring a drug to the
market unless you've tested it in a mice
and my question is why is that giving
the FDA any level of confidence that if
we don't see toxicity in mice we won't
see toxicity in humans or if we see
efficacy in mice will see efficacy in
humans because the actual evidence is
contrary to that that there is no
possibility of this flip-flop exchange
of information from one species to
another you know what they're doing it
the Twitter account called in mice it
takes headlines you know study shows
eating ice cream cures heart disease and
then it just retweets it with the words
in Vice
[Laughter]
it's that time of year when you're
doubtless buying presents for the people
you care about in your life so why not
buy a present for yourself in the form
of an audible membership now is the best
time to treat yourself to some
audiobooks and other audio specials with
an offer of 53 percent off your first
three months you can get of course all
of my books on audible most of them at
least the last two read by myself you
can get asura roses book the first sell
on audible
you can listen on any device anytime
anywhere with the audible app you can
choose three titles every month one
audiobook and two exclusive audible
originals you can't hear anywhere else
and right now for a limited time three
months of audible for just 695 a month
more than half off the regular price
visit audible.com slash mindscape or
text mindscape to 500 500 that's 5 0 0 -
5 0 0 go to audible.com slash mindscape
get my books get whatever book that
you've been thinking about treat
yourself it's the end of the year you're
worth it
yes so I got tired of the promotion of
this anecdotal person who has had
remission for four years on the
drugged that had failed in everybody the
question I asked is that yes it's true
that there are unicorns who have superb
inexplicable responses even to targeted
therapies that have failed in every
other patient and we don't have an
explanation of why they are responding
so well but we keep taking that as the
anecdote that we recount over and over
to say well that could happen the
question I'm asking is at the expense of
what at the expense of 99 out of 100
patients suffering unbearable toxicities
and medicines one rule that we begin
with this first do no harm so how can we
justify ourselves in an enterprise where
95% drugs are going to just harm and the
5% that we think won't harm will still
harm the majority of patients so instead
of constantly trying to improve the
typewriter we have to invent something
like the word processor to make that
obsolete in order to make the paradigm
shift to a better one we need to show a
better way because no one is going to
willingly give up what they're doing and
there is sort of a naive logic about
testing things on mice in the sense that
if it goes terribly wrong in the mouse
dies it's not as bad as it happening to
a human being but I think that you're
you have this idea that we can test
things on human cells or human tissues
without testing them on human beings and
maybe that's a better way to go yes
that's exactly well said you should be
giving this board no I think that's
exactly right that yes there are some
things we can't do in humans that we can
do in animal but we don't have to do
them there are other things that we can
do that we haven't even interrogated yes
yet so how do we do that how do we test
things out on human tissues or cells
without the whole human I think it was
in nineteen forties I think
that somebody said the best model for a
cat is another cat preferably the same
same cat yes they are different yes so
in other words what we need is we need
to test individual humans for their
disease and if we want to diagnose we
know that the only thing that works in
cancer is not in fact 1903 dr. children
England said this it's not the cancer
that kills but the delay in treatment
that kills so if we know that the
earlier we detect cancer the higher the
chances of cure why not try and develop
better techniques to detect cancer early
well this is not a new idea screening
measures for cancer were put into place
50 years ago screening how by
mammography by colonoscopy by pap smear
and by PSA measurements these are the
four most common screening measures used
and mortality from cancer has dropped by
26% in the last 30 years not because we
invented some new magic bullet but
because we're curing it no because of
two things one anti-smoking campaigns
and two screening measures even with
these four old screening measures we
have brought down the mortality but
these have been milk dry now this is the
maximum benefit we will get the present
rate for cancer mortality is only
declining by one percent a year and only
that is happening again not because of
new drugs coming on market but learning
to use existing chemotherapy radiation
therapy better and diagnosing cancer
earlier and earlier through more
sophisticated imaging scanning etcetera
techniques so what my point in the book
is simply we have done enough by trying
to chase the last cell we have used
artificial testing platforms clinical
drug development platforms these have
been
and spectacular failures and by the last
cell we mean the most recent cancer cell
in this cancerous growth rather than the
first one that appeared the last cell
means that after you have given all the
treatment you still think some residual
disease may be left behind and that is
the last cell I'm talking about so we
keep trying to develop sophisticated
techniques to molecular ly identify the
last cell I'm saying why not go not for
minimal residual disease but develop
techniques to determine minimal initial
disease and diagnose it cancer early in
fact and try to prevent it so instead of
using the standard screening measures I
described why not in this day and age of
godlike technology cutting and pasting
the DNA why not develop technologies
like you go to sleep in a in bed sheets
that scan you overnight for the presence
of a hotspot because remember I told you
a cancer when it begins divides faster
than normal cells so it needs more
nutrition it attracts more blood supply
area becomes hot it can be picked up by
scanning techniques
so the phrase hot spot is not
metaphorical is literally hotter a part
of your body that is higher than average
temperature yes for example a smart
Bryce now in clinical trial which is
fitted with mm and sensors that detect
changes in temperature and circadian
rhythms so the point is or you can sit
enough on something in the toilet in the
morning it's called the fit loo it takes
part of your urine and examines it for
the presence of biomarkers of malignancy
that are being met metabolites that may
be secreted or you can do a liquid
biopsy if somebody has colon cancer
as soon as cancer cells begin and start
proliferating they start shedding their
DNA into the blood you know where it
started actually it started with
mother-child placental bridge because it
turns out that since develop
mental abnormalities in an embryo in an
embryo increase with increasing maternal
age so an older woman becoming pregnant
has a higher chance of having an
abnormal developmentally abnormal baby
in order to diagnose those kinds of
syndromes like down syndromes etc we
used to put a long needle into the
uterus of the mother draw amniotic fluid
and look at it I underwent this
amniocentesis when I was pregnant
because I was 40 years old when I was
pregnant but then this was discovered
that the fetus is shedding its DNA into
maternal blood so cell-free fetal DNA
cff DNA is now the standard routine
thing all we need is a few drops of the
mother's blood now and we have the
health of the fetus reflected in those
few drops of blood or few cc's of blood
the same techniques have been applied to
cancer when cancer starts it also sheds
off cell-free DNA CF DNA into the blood
and so uses the mutated DNA that is that
you can't recover ends and just two
weeks ago it was announced by the
company Grail which is really going
after early detection of cancer they
announced that not only can they detect
cell-free DNA reliably 99% of the time
they can also say which organ it's
coming from so is it coming from
pancreas is it coming from the liver is
it coming from the lungs based on the
kind of mutations so this is the beauty
of very different disciplines of
knowledge coming together in a
conciliation to yield this kind of
information because the human genome was
sequenced 20 years ago practically but
now we are seeing the dividends of it
because we know what the normal DNA
should look like we can pick up a
mutation we can now detect I mean think
about it 20 years ago it took 15 years
and 2.7 billion dollars to do the first
human genome and sequencing
today it cost a few thousand dollars and
three weeks of sequencing so we become
efficient very quickly and I think that
if we start paying more attention to
these new types of techniques we need to
develop strategies to detect cancers
footprints in any secretion for example
blood sweat tears urine stool you can do
you can find by logic markers of DNA for
example some cancers which are beginning
let's say your bedsheets detected a spot
in my head of pancreas one night the
next morning it isn't necessary for me
to have an open abdominal proceed in a
Whipple's procedure and eviscerate my
whole belly no what it means is first I
should be monitored and then taken for
maybe even more sophisticated focused
scanning measures to make sure that this
thing is growing it's a real presence if
it is confirmed it's a real presence one
thing we can do is do a liquid biopsy
see if it's shedding anything in the
blood in the urine in tears and saliva
if we don't find it then we can still do
another thing we can yell at that spot
how do we yell using ultrasounds we hit
it with ultrasound when ultrasounds hit
this little mass it wiggles it shakes
and they shut off more protein so you
hit it yes bad and then you just do
another test of these liquid biopsies
from various places and now see if
you're detecting it and once you detect
it then you really confirm its potential
lethality because it may not necessarily
be very aggressive it may not need to be
removed right away it may not kill
someone who is 80 years for another 30
years so there's no need to go in so all
these markers of initial malignancy its
potential lethality its ability to
become invasive and aggressive those are
all pieces of information that can
actually be investigated with the
current tech sophisticated technology so
my point is we
present patience and we have future
patients we should divide up resources
into half and half half we should be
dedicating to the present patients half
to developing better technologies to
prevent and to detect early and prevent
the disease from becoming it's end-stage
monstrosity whereas right now it's not
fifty-fifty no it's five and ninety five
right now five percent for future
patient or future four for early
detection and four present patients what
we need to do also Shawn which I feel
very strongly about is we have to stop
hurting them I mean that is something we
need to stop giving everybody and the
simple the most obvious thing to do is
try and identify which patients are
likely to respond to which drugs how do
you do that well anytime a sponsor wants
to propose a clinical trial an
experimental trial they should be made
to save every sample from every patient
going on that first trial and then you
have some patients who respond some who
don't now you compare the responders and
non-responders using every technique you
have available genomics proteomics
transcriptomics metabolomic span omics
test by every way and try to enrich the
next trial for patients who are likely
to respond and so on and so forth
today that clinical trials are done the
same way they were being done in 1977
and it is horrifying to me that the
agencies which have been charged with
protecting patients and demanding this
kind of rigor are not doing it I think
that the this sounds very provocative
and promising and so forth that the idea
there was the scientific idea that I
that I get from it that is most exciting
to me is the idea of the footprints of
the cancer I mean the wearing a blanket
and finding a hot spot sounds
interesting but that's literally looking
for the tumor in your body whereas this
sort of indirect idea that once there's
a tumor in your body
it leaves traces either from DNA and
correct me if I'm wrong from reading
your book but you can find tracers of
the fact that your immune system is
beginning to fight it also in your blood
is there another way of doing it yes
definitely in fact I have a the best way
that would emerge eventually it's a
collection of all of this technology
which is imaging and scanning and
devices and biomarkers and genetic
markers all these put together and all
being read by something no bigger than
your cell phone and all the information
available on this but then even
implantable devices I mean I'm working
with biomedical engineers at Columbia
University on a chip that we want to
implant under the skin from birth to
death which constantly should be
monitoring the idea is that even the
screening techniques we used so far
brought down the mortality considerably
but it's not happening anymore because
they have reached their limit but those
were done annually at best we want to
treat the human body as if it is a
machine and constantly monitor it for
even the appearance of perturbations and
disease caused networks and you see that
and you step in and try to intervene so
this many of the same drugs which are
failing today can be applied in earlier
stages of the disease and may be far
more effective and this has been shown
as a paradigm in chronic myeloid
leukemia and the disease I mentioned to
you for which a targeted therapy is the
ideal for every cancer well in that
cancer itself as long as it is chronic
myeloid leukemia that drug is all is
curative but if the disease starts to
accelerate becomes acute leukemia and
the same drug is useless so earlier
stages the same drugs can work well
that's what I wanted to pinpoint also so
I mean it seems obviously true that if
you can find the disease earlier you
have a better chance of curing it but
how far can we go in saying that you
know if we find it very very early does
our chances of curing the disease go
very very high or
does it increase by 10% my answer is it
will be hundred percent okay more
curable why because of all the
statistics that are available the
earlier you find cancer the better
you're able to cure it but the issue is
how quickly are we able to do it and
then technologies will also evolve for
treatment of early disease so if you
guys kind of things to do yes so let's
say you have a million cells to kill
rather than a hundred and fifty billion
cells to kill there's a big difference
so I think for example if you needed
radiation therapy to kill a hundred
billion cells you may need just a
targeted laser to knock off a few
million cells quite confidently or you
can use immune cellular therapies that
if we have a biomarker we can arm the
killer cells of the immune system with
it and it will be able to distinguish
them between the cancer in the normal
cells
the current cellular therapies we are
using or unable to distinguish between
cancer cells and normal cells that's why
the toxicities of sake RT therapy
because it will kill every cell that
it's expressing that marker which means
normal cells as well as cancer cells I'm
saying that once we have biomarker
specific for cancer cells we may have an
address for the cancer cell also that is
more usable by these the same techniques
which are causing so much toxicity and
it sounds like this is great because
it's not just an aspiration it's not
just a sort of feel-good motto that if
we found the cancer earlier we could
help cure it quicker more effectively
but that there are very concrete steps
being taken is this how popular is this
view in the community is this a plucky
minority or is it catching on as that
this is what we should be concentrating
on right now it's so all of these things
I described to you are in various stages
of development so everyone has known for
50 years that the best strategy is to go
early and people have
and a lot of time in screening and
trying to make those as accurate as
possible and in the last 10-15 years
people have started developing all this
new technology based on the evolving
genomic information and proteomics etc
that's becoming available so clearly
those things are all in various stages
of development it's not a pie in the sky
but we the more resources we need the
more people will get interested and
young minds who are today wasting their
time and talent and intellect on failing
models because they are working with
mentors who for 30 years have used those
failing models and they are the ones
sitting in every granting agency
deciding who gets the grant and who gets
to scratch who was back this is all has
to stop and young minds and young risk
intellect as well as resources should be
better used I think and new technology
new ideas new therapies will bring their
own set of problems so I'm not someone
who's going to all our problems will be
resolved because I'm an old hag I've
been being there done that in all kinds
of things but I do think that it is time
to recognize at least where we are
failing time to take off our blinders
time to at least describe the problem in
its detail and see the problem for what
it is right now we are not even willing
to see the problem it's not that we are
just not finding the solution we refuse
to look at the details of what we are
doing wrong my insistence is to look at
all of this through the prism of human
anguish because this is not just some
cut-and-dried science this involves
humans this involves a 22 year old
Andrew or a 38 year old Omer or my
patient JC who died at 34 or Harvey who
was diagnosed four with his first cancer
and then at 34 in his second cancer at
57 and this is one thing I want to also
recount to you Sean that my life
has been committed to early detection
since 1984 you know why because I
started by studying acute myeloid
leukemia and treating patients with it
within a short space of seven years it
became clear to me that in my lifetime
this disease is so aggressive we will
not be able to cure it and I was right
unfortunately we were using seven and
three then we are using seven and three
now in 1984 because of a patient JC I
realized that the best way to handle
acute myeloid leukemia is to stop the
disease before it becomes so aggressive
are there patients like that yes it's a
whole series of syndromes called my low
dysplastic syndromes which are pre
leukemic because a third of these
patients can develop acute myeloid
leukemia my idea was well then we should
study pre leukemia and follow these
patients through and had I gone to
school in this country at this point I
would have invested the rest of my life
into making a mouse model of this free
leukemia but coming from Pakistan is a
fresh immigrant I trusted my instinct
rather than followed custom and I
decided oh I'm going to study these
patients let me save their samples so I
just started banking blood bone marrow
aspirate biopsies normal buccal smears
germline controls on all my patients so
by saving them you don't mean saving the
data you mean literally saving the
tissues both no I mean both the data as
well as the actual samples it's the most
well annotated tissue repository which
today has more than 60,000 samples from
thousands of patients and not one cell
has come from a different doctor every
patient is my patient do you want other
doctors to contribute to this it's very
expensive they can't afford to do it I'm
the only one who does it because I pay
for it and how do I pay for it no grant
ofor can support it my patients support
it for me I ask them and they they want
to give me money and I say no I don't
want personal money give it to the
tissue repository because it costs
almost a million dollars a year just to
maintain the tissue repository so point
is that I have these samples which were
obtained in a longitudinal fashion
serially on these thousands of patients
as they progress from pre leukemia to
acute leukemia now if we go in and study
these samples and work our way back we
can at the end go and ask the question
why did this a healthy individual even
get pre leukemia was there a genetic
mutation that made them susceptible or
at high risk for it what was it about
their exposome environment exposure what
was there about their background their
inherited DNA and so those kinds of
questions we can then take to the DNA
sequences that are in the public domain
from hundreds of thousands of healthy
volunteers and find out how many people
fit our bill for being at high risk of
developing even pre leukemia and then
following those healthy individuals to
find whether they develop it or not and
how quickly can we stop it there this is
the kind of thing we need to do the
problem is so it took me so long to
amass the samples even today I am doing
five to ten bone marrows every week in
my clinic in my with my own hands I do
the bone marrows and banking them so I
have all this tissue the technology has
caught up we need resources right who's
going to give the resources the
government can't fold it because I need
a hundred million dollars to study the
whole repository it isn't as if I
haven't been studying it Sean of course
over the last 30 years I have over 300
original publications which are
reporting on the results we find from
limited samples we take out study it for
one gene or that signaling pathway or
this drug or that kind of thing with
limited questions clearly now that all
the technology has arrived and we need
to go in and study the entire tissue
repository that is a
thing that no one can know government
grant can support hundred million
dollars to one individual and I don't
need the money to set up you know a
building with 70 scientists working in
it no this is money that's needed to pay
for the actual tests for the samples to
do the proteomics on two hundred
patients
cost four million dollars this is the
kind of that's that's where the money
will go so the other idea that occurred
to me was if there are any mindscape
listeners out there who would like to
donate a hundred million dollars the
tissue repository will encourage them to
do that I mean can you just I'd like to
try to give the the audience a sort of
visceral feel for what it's like to be
doing this kind of work number one let
me just mention this kind of
longitudinal study is the gold standard
in science and social sciences
especially and really hard and expensive
to do because you have to start young
and continue to be dedicated and get the
resources but how like where is it where
are these tissues like are they in a
room somewhere they kept cold or they do
do they still duplicate the cells or is
there a finite number of cells that we
use up so it's then tied tissue
repository is housed at Columbia
University Cancer Center it moved with
me from Buffalo to Cincinnati to Chicago
to Massachusetts to New York now and it
is since 1984 which travelled with me
and these are samples which are in ref
in freezers but in addition we have
frozen viable tissue also which can be
brought out and re grown in plates and
animals in vitro in vivo so it's an
immense collection of samples everything
belongs to Columbia University I don't
have any companies to my name I don't
need any personal money this is all
going to go through Columbia University
so one thing that occurred to me Sean is
that the people who should be most
interested in finding the first cell are
the people who are at highest risk of
in cancer who are those people they're
people like Harvey my late husband
people who have one cancer and I don't
want to scare your listeners at all but
I do want to say that one in five you
can say is diagnosed in a cancer
survivor
mmm-hmm because whatever was there to
cause the first cancer is still there
the conditions are still the conditions
are there and probably with our
treatment for some of them we have made
the conditions worse because Harvey did
not die of his cancer he died because we
wiped out his immune system with the
horrible chemotherapy we gave him so the
point is the people at highest risk
should be the most interested today in
this country there are 20 million
survivors from cancer even if 1 million
of them just give $10 a month for a year
that's it that will fund the whole
tissue repository people ask me dr. Reza
why should we give you money and not to
the American Cancer Society my answer is
where's the tissue for American Cancer
Society talk is cheap Sean but I am the
one who has the tissue I'm the one who
has the commitment to early detection
because I've been going after not just
acute leukemia but pre leukemia since
1984 I've been saying the same thing
since 1984 how much more credibility can
I give people are very quick to start
criticizing me oh she's talking about
the first cell she has she doesn't know
how much screening measures have failed
I know
nobody needs to lecture me about these
things because not only do I see 30 to
40 cancer patients every week I have had
a cutting-edge research lab for 35 plus
years and I'm a cancer widow so I have
stood on both sides of the bed of a
cancer patient as well as a family
member as well as an oncologist so there
is really very little that I have not
experienced directly in firsthand and I
have been consistently committed to
finding cancer at its earliest possible
cell and try to take care of
to prevent the disease from happening
and if people don't trust me by now and
don't want to support this tissue
repository then I don't know who will
all I can say is as long as there is one
breath left in my body I will keep
saying the same thing and trying to work
as hard as ever for my patients I can't
think of a better place to end up than
that that was very eloquently said dr.
Alver Rosa thanks so much for being on
the mindscape podcast Thank You Sean it
has been an honor being on your podcast
[Music]
you
[Music]